a big thing that I'm trying to do with
my YouTube is I feel like there's not a
lot of great communication that is
accessible and welcoming to Ordinary
People about what is happening in the
economy and then people see what's
happening and you know you don't need me
to tell you things have been getting
really difficult for a lot of people in
the last few years and they don't
understand why nobody's explaining why
you know which is you know I think one
of the part of the problem is kids like
me and other people who have done very
well at economics University yeah how
much money you going to make talking to
people about Finance and when you can
make millions of pounds a year working
did